one of the reasons that Palestinians
don't have this knowledge about the
captions and different cities of
Palestine is that Israel has
disconnected different cities and
regions and geographies in Palestine so
we don't have physical accessibility to
those places produce the food practices
that differ one place to the other
my name is Mira Banyan I'm an artist of
cook and founder of Palestine hosting
society
Palestine hosting site is a live art
project it seeks to create a platform
for people to construct the relationship
to geography politics history but
through food do you have Israeli chefs
dealing with our food culture without
actually knowing the backstory of those
dishes when you oppress that story you
are using food as a as a tool for
oppression after picking the topic or
the city that I want to delve more into
I go to the place and I spent a month or
two in that place and I meet people 3
1948 Nakba generation the ones that have
experienced this very sudden rupture
from the land and have moved all over
the world with them food they're moved
but as well with them a food was
forgotten and I meet the mothers as well
to understand what this shows they still
cook and they don't cook but as well I
meet men whether in small shops in old
cities old restaurants most of the
people that I interviewed were exiled
[Music]
one of the dishes that I was happy to
put on the menu of the edible art glass
table was roof it's a very Palestinian
plant even a scientific name of that
article still it has Palestine in the
name of it
so roof is a poisonous plant when it's
eaten as it is straight from the land it
numbs the mouth and it can even have
more serious and complications if it was
consumed without being treated our
grandmothers knew how to treat that
plant by curing it with salt and olive
oil and then cooked over a long period
of time the recipes have this power of
movement that most of us Palestinians
are not having read discovered during my
research sister LaRue and this is a very
very old ancient dish it's roasted
semolina with olive orange with carob
molasses and some people add tahini and
sesame to it it used to be the food that
travelers and pilgrims carried with them
when they travel because it has all this
richness of the nutrients and energy to
it every table we create is very
detailed from the napkins that we have
on the tables from the centerpieces from
what we place the water and
when I present the menu
I do the performance it's the artist who
becomes the vehicle of transferring this
knowledge on the table they're not
plated one-by-one because I want to
maintain this sharing aspect of food
which is very much in our culture for
Palestinians as a farmer nation we
always had this very intimate connection
with the land our grandfathers knew the
land really well it was their world my
generation are those that must is
knowledge we're the generation that had
to assimilate and learn new places where
the refugee camps where they're outside
of Palestine whether in new cities the
people who attend the tables of
Palestine hosting society are from
different backgrounds and with each new
table we have new people who attend when
we as Palestinians see our ingredients
being sold under the name of Israeli
produce it's a very hard moment for us
somehow it refreshes the trauma of us
losing the land of us not having power
over our existence the land not the
space that you live on but the place
were in practice your being as a human
being as Palestinian as a culture as a
lineage of ancestors and it's a story
that we have to reclaim now in the
present so we can pass it to the future
[Music]